maintenant c'est une histoire qui
coupent l'appétit il à cette heure du
souper et qui met aussi le secteur
alimentaire chinois sur la sellette
parce que les restaurants mcdonald's au
japon et à hong kong ont cessé de vendre
des produits à base de poulet qui
provient de la chine
donc jean philippe ce qu'une usine de
shanghai est impliqué dans un scandale
sanitaire l'expliqué nous sommes
effectivement à tous aux ulis a commencé
en début de semaine c'est la suite d'un
reportage a été diffusé par la
télévision chinoise et ce reportage dans
les journalistes dans le fond de nous
amener à l'intérieur d'une usine l'usiné
de la compagnie aussi c'est à shanghai
et quand vous allez voir les images les
comprendre effectivement que c'est pas
très très dur et boutin on voit des
employés par exemple ramasser des pièces
de viande par terre on voit également
des employés mélanger des pièces de
viande de poulet primé avec des pièces
de viande qui était beaucoup plus
fraîche alors et c'est toute cette
viande lassadi en deux poules elles
étaient destinées à des grandes chaînes
de restaurants en chine et au japon
on pense entre autres à mcdonald's on
pense entre autres à burger king à
poulet frit kentucky depuis faut
mentionner l'usiné a été fermée il ya
cinq employés qui ont été arrêtées et
bien sûr les chaînes de restaurant en
asie elles ont réagi à ce qui a été fait
par exemple c'est qu'il ya des certaines
grandes chaînes julie qui ont arrêté de
faire affaire avec cette cette
entreprise là alors que mcdonald's à
l'heure actuelle ne vend plus de mecs
croquettes là entre autres à hong kong
et au japon
bon alors vous comprendrez l'on vous
écoute on se demandait ce que ça touche
aussi des restaurants canadiens oui
c'est la grande question qu'on se pose
effectivement en regardant le reportage
alors aujourd'hui on a tenté d'avoir
davantage d'informations
évidemment canada et la chine c'est très
très différent parce qu'ici au canada
julie on a des mesures de contrôle on a
des mécanismes qui font en sorte que ce
genre d'événement l'eau serait serait
difficilement impossible invités écoutez
un des porte parole de l'industrie
c'est une possibilité très très petit
d'ici au canada parce que nous avons des
règlementations très très très clair et
puis nous avons lagence canadien de
l'inspection des aliments qui est
présent dans les usines
dans les abattoirs ils sont toujours
présents pour faire la vérification du
processus vous souvenez sans doute julie
d'abord c'est pas le premier scandale
alimentaire qui arrive en chine vous
semblez vous souvenez sans doute il ya
quelques années je prétends en 2008 de
ce lait contaminé à la mélamine qui
avait en fait entre autres six victimes
deux jeunes enfants et trois cent mille
personnes là qui étaient tombés malades
alors voila merci beaucoup pour les
précisions y'a pas toi au revoir